Now, that is an incredibly important thing.
To see your background, your experience,
yourhistory represented
out there in the world,
having a voice, speaking on a platform,
doingthe things that perhaps you
hope that you would be able to do.
If you can't see yourself out there
or anyone who looks like you
or sounds like you,
it's very hard to imagine
that you'll beable to do that as well.
And that’s one part
of what was incredibly important,
I've realizedover the years,
of what was incredibly important about
me being able to have the life
and theopportunities
and the career that I've had.
But it's only one part.
I've realized moreand more
as time has gone on
how much I owe
everything, all the opportunities I've had,
to other people
and the work of other people.